bear markets are just opportunities  where some of the greatest wealth is  built but what I will say is to focus  more on bitcoin that's the one which is  the safest it's the only cryptocurrency  which is truly decentralized Buy on  those centralized exchanges but remove  it take self-custody what I want people  to realize is now is the most important  time because censorship is Rife we're  seeing people have their bank accounts  Frozen for saying the incorrect thing  PayPal are finding people for so-called  misinformation and so we do not want to  have a centralized entities having any  form of control you mentioned the  European Central Bank but it was  actually the EU that confiscated  people's life savings in Cyprus back in  2013. people woke up one day with  absolutely nothing left so the idea here  is we do not want to trust our money no  with these institutions we're central  banks with governments we want to hold  Bitcoin in a non-custodial way